[Music]
everybody we are back from our Caribbean
cruise and we had a blast so you look
Tanner I think I look Tanner actually
I'm kind of feeling a little bit here
and there a little to taenia yes so big
humongous gigantic thank you to Royal
Caribbean for inviting us out to check
out perfect day at cook okay we got to
enjoy a beautiful most relaxing most
adventurous three-day cruise at the
Bahamas it was incredible we had a blast
Isaac is already telling me how much he
misses the cruise like every day he's
been saying like I asked him one day I
was like how long do you think you'd be
on cruise for he was like half a year so
he definitely loved it I definitely
loved it
and we wanted to talk about our
experience and share it with you guys so
I really enjoyed just stepping on the
actual ship seeing everything that the
ship has to offer it was just so
exciting and it was just like I could
see Isaac really excited we end up
heading over to our room and our room
had a amazing view so we got this
balcony view that overlooks the ocean
the answer on the navigator of the Seas
about to experience our very first Royal
Caribbean cruise oh my goodness I'm so
excited we're headed to perfect day at
CoCo Key tomorrow we get to experience
this very private island with an amazing
waterpark dude that yeah we're about to
have a blast and then so we ended up
walking around the ship we saw the
arcade we spent some time at the arcade
and it was pretty fun and then we ended
up having a steak dinner and chopped the
restaurant onboard and that was so
what'd you think of that foodie it's one
of those things when you get on a ship
and you're out at sea you don't expect
to have like amazing quality food but it
was amazing it was one of the best
except ahead in my life and then after
dinner we ended up going to see it ice
skating show and that show was
incredible once I made the announcements
on the ship like oh yeah make sure to
show that that ice skating show I
thought ice skating like I just picked
her like a tiny like rinky-dink little
rink but no this place blew my mind I
was like what they had so many ice
skating performers too and then at the
beginning of the show they had this
aerial and Rome show like a light show
using tiny little drones which I loved
anything I was freaking out for that but
it was it like totally blew my mind
honestly that first night it was like
the perfect family night for us we had
such a great time together and we were
just bonding I think could just not wait
to test out the water sides that's one
thing he just kept telling me Mommy when
can we get in the water site when can we
go in on my future wait till the next
day enjoy the ship enjoy it like you
know just enjoy family time we'll get
there good morning good morning we are
now docked at perfect day at Koko K I'm
so excited to check out this private
island now you can only get to via a
Royal Caribbean cruise we are about to
explore you're excited yeah private
island just for you sir
whoo we're about to go ziplining though
that's what I gotta shoes on close toed
shoes for the win
[Music]
[Music]
the very first thing we did as soon as
we got off the ship was head straight to
the zip line and it was literally the
very first most perfect thing we could
have done on the island cuz we got to
have an aerial view of the whole island
and it was really fun it was so gorgeous
and it was so funny too because Isaac
immediately ditched us like he just huge
petrol hearse one that took that went on
the lines and so each Tower there were
three three towers of three lines but
each one he just kept advancing faster
and faster he just couldn't wait to
continue on the ziplining I mean that
was perfect for Casey and I cuz I really
love having like our own little romantic
moment and even a romantic gliding yeah
it was really cute to use a lot of the
workers were like yeah we kept ask me
Isaac if you wanted away from for his
parents or not but so then right after
the zipline we went straight to North
America's tallest waterslide I'm gonna
let that sink in a little bit North
America's tallest waterslide that was so
much fun so it was also pretty funny
don't do that all at one first Devil's
Peak
you're nervous I don't know warm up
there just move up for the tallest one
and then we'll work our way down to the
shorter ones drill and junkie fee
because I'm such an adrenaline junkie I
was like we have to do the Telus one
first it has to be the first thing we do
like I just wanted to eat my dessert
right away Isaac in Casey they were like
really okay
I am scared you're scared how come I
don't know yeah we're pretty up high to
you right now I don't know it's because
I don't think I've gone another
waterslides it in ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I do I want it how is it yeah
yeah so the island
it actually has 13 water slides and I
made sure you got to experience every
single one and obviously I did - oh we
ended up having a blast
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and she was towards the end of the day
and I guess most of the crowd wanted to
do other things because Hill Island was
legit so whatever it was they were there
were almost no people there so it felt
like we had our own private beach it was
really fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's artistic you're just messing
around it was really fun though I liked
it those are the true family moments
feel like there's little moments you
cherish yeah exactly that's pretty fun
it was just a nice calming relaxing like
really taking the time to sit back and
like soak everything in and be like whoa
we're really here right now a little bit
of mindfulness you know yeah it was
really cool I honestly am now like a
Cruz fan cuz we had taken a cruise once
before and to be completely honest that
other cruise made me feel like I will
never cruise again so then we got this
opportunity we're real Caribbean we're
like well it is on the other side of the
country maybe it'll be a different
experience and plus Royal Caribbean like
their brand is just so fun and so
outgoing and we're just like this really
aligns with Baltimore us yeah it's
totally more up so we're like alright
let's see let's check this out and give
it a chance and to be completely honest
guys even though they did take us out I
am such a Royal Caribbean fan like I
cannot wait for the next cruise we can
take their album
oh my god that was really kind of like
the icing on top the app I mean that's
not necessarily part of like the whole
island experience and stuff but honestly
the Royal Caribbean app is a thing of
beauty it is so gorgeous like the
graphics on it is really pretty but it's
also so helpful because it tells you it
like where you you can go on the ship
and not just the ship but the island
itself too and it just it hasn't this
really beautiful map and it's just so
interactive like when when they're ship
leaving it that's all everything like
all that even your dinner reservations
you know all that stuff and like even
for the shows like the ice-skating shows
like he'll tell you at this time and at
this deck and it was just so helpful
I don't know I'm keeping that on my
phone and I can't wait to the next time
we get to do into the cruiser Royal
Caribbean it was really fun I really
hope you guys get to check it out
sometime and if you have checked it out
leave in the comments below your most
favorite moments your favorite activity
you got to experience a Royal Caribbean
because they'll give us some ideas for
the next vacation
[Music]